[Music]
following on from the last video this is
about running the resistance solo to
farm classified gear this isn't the only
way of running it I've just found this
way to be quite easy particularly when
using the Builder showed in the last
video there are more efficient builds to
solo farm the resistance but this is a
nice easy place to start before getting
into the builds that deal more damage
and are a bit more flexible but they can
also be a little bit more punishing when
slipping up there is potential to farm
up to four classified items by wave ten
but you'll need a bit of practice PC
users will find this a little bit easier
to achieve each run will take you around
20 to 30 minutes depending on how fast
you clear some of the earlier waves I
ran this quite a few times to get good
clips showing how to manage you get the
best out of each wave but instead I
decided to use some footage of me making
a few mistakes only managing to get
three reward chests open and wave 10
Plus this is probably a more realistic
number that you'll be achieving the
first few times you go through this and
I'll be able to point out where I went
wrong and what could have been done a
little better with practice you'll get
more out of the shape tech earning waves
and spend less on extra medkits and mo
and turn giving you more rewards at the
end of the day though whether you get
open the chests two times or four times
there is no guarantee that you'll get a
classified item out of it but there's a
pretty good chance opening the chest
gives you one reward there is a 57 point
one percent chance of that reward being
a classified item fourteen point three
percent chance of beings and exotic and
a twenty eight point six percent chance
of it being a standard gear set item
in waves 1 2 & 3 there's no rush
just run through it at your own pace try
not to use any mo who we want to keep as
much as possible for later rounds make
sure you're only reloading in your mo
station and if you need to leave it for
some reason use your pistol the first
couple of waves are feel easy you can
see here that have perched myself at the
entrance to create a little bit of a
funnel but you don't need to do this
souls just being lazy in fact this
actually hinders me a bit later on at
the end of wave 3 the full wave force
starts run over to the door and preload
it and what I mean by this is start
loading it up with credits but don't
open it this is quite important that you
remove to do this and you'll see why
variously
you smell pretty - standing objective
NextWave apostle's 20 seconds
this is an object scanning wave which
means you have to run over to a laptop
and scan it within the 3-minute timer
and while this is happening there is an
infinite wave of enemies coming at you
yep this is our first shaped tick
earning wave the trick to this is that
you don't actually need to have finished
scanning the laptop before the timer
runs out you just need to be in the
process of scanning so you want to leave
this as late as possible and in the
meantime kill as many NPCs as possible
maximizing the amount of shade tick you
gain from the wave stay in this first
room as it limits the distance at which
enemies can spawn from you meaning you
can kill them easier and faster what
I've done wrong here is I kept my little
hidey-hole rather than getting out there
and taking down NPCs as fast as possible
essentially wasting about 30 seconds of
kill time and this is a good example of
how something quite small can affect the
number of rewards that you can get at
the end of the run when there's about 40
seconds left on the clock run over to
the door and pop in the rest of the
credits to open it up you'll be under a
bit of fire and this is why we've
pre-loaded the door earlier
run straight to the objective as long as
you get there before the timer runs out
you'll be fine while you're scanning
keep killing NPCs and don't step out a
range of the scanning
once you've finished scanning kill all
the remaining enemies bar one leave one
alive so that the next wave doesn't
start giving you time to run around and
collect all of the shape tick
after hit back to the start but before
you go inside take a lift and you'll
find a door into the delivery dock open
up the store and head up the ladder into
this area and get comfortable you'll be
spending the next few waves in here the
last NPC will have followed you in or
teleported in front of you
kill them when you're ready to start the
next round this is a good spot because
the door behind you is closed right now
so the only way the NPC's could get to
you is through the hallway in front of
you so you don't have to worry about
getting flanked plus everything is in a
comfortable shooting range so this is a
boss wave and like wave 4 you have a
timer except this time you need to kill
the boss within that time so the best
tactic is to take the bosses shield off
and then farm NPCs until it's about 10
or 20 seconds left
remember to conserve ammo where you can
place your ammo station around the
corner so it doesn't get shot at there
is a few different potential bosses that
could spawn but regardless treat them
the same way damage them and then ignore
them while killing other NPCs this
should be easy enough using the shield
in this example the NPC sport messed up
somehow they stopped running in I should
have run through and cleared them a
little sooner to reset the spawning but
most of the time this wouldn't happen
they just continually streaming towards
you
eliminate all remaining enemies
like waves 1 2 3 these are pretty chill
there is only a seat amount of enemies
so just stay in the same area and take
them down at your own pace
[Music]
this is an objective scanning wave so
like wave 4 leave it as late as possible
before scanning sit back and take down
the enemies as quickly as possible there
will be a lot of shotguns rushing at you
but that's good they're perfect for this
build because they're quick to take down
and they come right up to your face but
you do want to keep an eye on your
shield health because they do a bit of
damage with about 40 or 50 seconds to go
depending on how confident you're
feeling run through and make your way to
the objective remember to leave one
enemy remaining at the end again so you
can run around collecting the shade tick
but also once you've done that we're
going to run over and click your first
rewards
[Music]
here you can see me purchasing some
extra ammo if you run this properly with
your ammo station you shouldn't need to
do this but if you do need it you can
buy extra ammo and meat kits at these
two chests at the bottom of the letter
you can buy them using shape tech but
the more often you do it the more it
will cost and of course that means less
shape tech towards your rewards go back
through to the delivery docks back up
the ladder and then open up the storage
bay to door and then run through this
room and open up the AV storage door on
the right you'll see the resistance
reward chest wind running solo the first
reward will cost 1500 shade tech with
each reward after that costing an
additional 1,500 on top of the last one
this is still quite viable running this
farm with a friend but opening the
chests cost double what it would win
running solo but it has the added
advantage of being able to share what
you get as you can see I've only managed
open two but in the next couple of waves
you'll be able to comfortably open
another third or fourth reward if you're
willing to go further when you're ready
to proceed kill the last NPC
this is a contamination wave which
basically means you'll be getting
damaged slowly over time though there is
only a set number of enemies you'll want
to be a little more proactive and
hunting down the NPC's even though you
have an ammo station your main form of
healing is going to be through your
health on kill so get out there and
chain down the enemies quickly and you
shouldn't have a problem making it
through this wave so when you're
finished run back and open up another
chest or if you need to get a little
more get prepared for the next boss wave
this build is more than capable of
running through the wave ten bosses so
like the last boss way if you have a
timer but this time there will be two
bosses take down one of the bosses early
and damage the second one and then just
farm NPCs until just before the timer
runs out and then drop the second boss
you can continue to run through up into
wave 15 you probably won't be able to
take down the 300 bosses but usually
after completing wave 10 you just
restart
[Music]
this has been run on Pier 93 but the
same principles can be applied to the
other two maps as well this is just one
way of running this mission you might
find other areas a little more
comfortable to defend and find when you
get used to doing it this way experiment
with other areas the video you just
watched shows a more realistic outcome
of what you'll get from this farm but
remember with a little bit of practice
you'll be able to get more my next
couple of videos will show some other
ninja bike build options for soloing the
resistance thanks for watching if this
helped at all please let me know in the
comments I'd like to know if you think I
provided maybe too much information or
maybe I didn't go into enough detail but
otherwise Cheers
[Music]